من أجل بضعة أرغفة من الخبز ،
يخاطر سكان الكوبيون بحياتهم
[موسيقى]
استعادت القوات الأوكرانية المدينة
منذ حوالي أسبوعين ، لكن القتال بعيدًا
عن نهايته ، وصفته جوليا بكلمة واحدة
أنها صدى للقنابل العنقودية التي تسقط على
مسافة ليست بعيدة
أحيانًا.  يقول دانيلو خائفًا
من صوت القصف القريب في بعض الأحيان
لا يهمني هؤلاء هم الأشخاص القلائل الذين بقوا
في كوبانسكا هذه المدينة على الرغم من
أن الروس نظريًا تركوا
الروس لمجرد عبور النهر
وفي الواقع وفقًا للجنود هنا
لا يزال هناك روس داخل
الجزء الخاضع للسيطرة الأوكرانية من المدينة
التي سيطرت عليها القوات الروسية على كوبيانسك
مع قتال ضئيل في الأيام الأولى
من الحرب ، فقد كانت بمثابة المركز
الإداري للجزء المحتل من روسيا من منطقة
خاركيف.
دفع الروس رواتب ومعاشات تقاعدية
، وتحول الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني الأخير
المدينة إلى
منطقة حرب مما أثار الاستياء
من الجانبين.
مرحبًا ، يقول أحدهم إن الحالة
المزاجية للسكان مصدومة من السابق
لأوانه ومن الخطورة جدًا البدء في
إزالة حطام الأنقاض الذي لا يزال مبعثرًا
في الشوارع ،
حسنًا ، هناك فكرة ثابتة إلى حد ما
حول
إطلاق المدفعية والقذائف الصاروخية الواردة والصادرة
هنا  على بعد ساعة بالسيارة في بلدة
إيسيوم ، لا يوجد قصف ، لكن صدمة القذيفة لا تزال
تظهر على وجوه الأشخاص الذين ينتظرون
الطعام ، وقد تحرك القتال على الندوب التي
تركها عميقاً
التي أصابت بيتي.
أصبحت
مستودعًا للإمدادات التي تبرعت بها بلدة
بالقرب من كييف بين ذراعي جدها
ألينا تتذكر القصف المكثف
الذي قتل كلبنا وأصيب بالسقف الذي
كنا نختبئ فيه في الطابق السفلي.